good evening welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored at First Sight the British
Monarchy should already be finished
let's face it many people see privilege
as a crime against equal opportunity the
monarchy meanwhile is undeniably built
on illogical birthrights populism rages
against Elites but the raw family are
the most obvious Elites of them all
tribalism and Brash opinions dominate
public debate in an age of identity
politics but were quietly ruled by an
unspeaking authority that takes
absolutely no position and that's really
the whole point fickle politicians tear
strips of each other and Survive by
dividing us but the monarchy is a
constant reassuring Above The Fray
that's why it's not only survived but
thrived Against All Odds but there is
growing evidence of cracks in Britain's
gilded Edge Hamza Youssef who's the
front runner to be Scotland's next
leader has put the future of the
monarchy firmly on the table
I'm a republican I believe that we
should be Citizens First not subjects we
keep the monarchy for a period of time
then I'd hope Scotland and independent
Scotland been moved to be a republican
the future
well since then Mr Youssef has doubled
down on his statement promising to give
the Scottish people a vote on whether to
have a monarch or an elected head of
state within five years and then
independent of Scotland is not the only
threat to the monarchy the late Queen
was emphatically more popular than King
Charles for now anyway and young people
are much less enthusiastic about the
monarchy Harry and Megan's Antics and
that a global Crusade is smears against
an unfashable and what they tried to
call a racist institution Prince
Andrew's squalid Scandal has heaped
massive embarrassment on the winses and
indeed the institution of the monarchy
Australia has scrubbed King Charles from
his banknotes Barbados ditched the lake
queen as head of state Jamaica will be
next to become a Republic and the Royals
are Barrett by protests and demands for
reparations whenever they tour the
Commonwealth force in King Charles to
say this
from The Darkest Days of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
the people of this island forged their
path with extraordinary fortitude
well whether the body can survive the
error of constant hammering apologies
the historical sins is suddenly a rather
urgent question but it should the
monarchy keeps our sense of nation and
patriotism separate from politics it
gives us a reason to unite love our
country it's traditions and its identity
it's above the Venom of everyday
political debate we're confused the head
of state with the head of government
like the U.S or turkey or Brazil would
that really bring us closer together so
evidence that it does
God forbid we have a ballot of president
farage
we could have a ceremonial Overlord like
Germany or Ireland who cuts ribbons and
shakes hands with the cameras but is
that seriously any better for brown
Britain than the Pomp and pageantry of
our oldest greatest tradition the Royal
sometimes disappointers they're not
perfect they're humans but the monarchy
is worth defending I guess political
attacks like this one from a Scottish
nationalists and it starts with
celebrating it not constantly
apologizing for its past well joining me
now is the former first minister of
Scotland Alex salmon talked to a
contributor Paula Roan Adrian and chief
executive of the campaign group Republic
Graham Smith welcome to you all so
Alexander
um
don't know much about him although he's
popped up may replace Nicholas surgeon
from all the polls yes the book is
favorite yeah uh which is probably never
a place you really want to find yourself
at this stage of the race but he is
clearly not a monarchistilia thinks we
should just get rid of the monarchy do
you agree with him I think he's probably
right I mean it was different when I was
first Minister the queen was head of
state you had to be insane to to suggest
replacing Her Majesty the queen because
of her long service her popularity her
wisdom
what different situation now and it's
quite interesting if you ask people in
Scotland do you want to keep the
monarchy or get the Republic you'll
probably get a majority for the monarchy
if you ask the question if you're
setting up an independent Scotland a new
country should just start with an
elected head of state then the answer is
quite different you shouldn't you should
move to uh an elected head of state as
opposed to the hereditary principle so
what do you think what is your intrinsic
argument about the monarchy because the
arguments I hear against it is well they
cost too much money but that's probably
not true well they're a net positive
that's not my arguments all right so I'm
sure it might be one of yours but we'll
part them because if they're a net
positive so is it just the idea of
unelected family which is at the head of
the country I think if you're setting up
a a new Democratic country you wouldn't
start from the hereditary principle the
monarchy
why not well why not I don't know well
in recent times I mean if you go back a
hundred years new countries started with
new money I mean you know like Norway
imported I don't know a minor German
line from somewhere if I remember
correctly remember a minor Swedish line
but right now in the 21st century you
wouldn't start from the Henry principle
uh also I I tend to I think there's a
presidential test in this piece see if
Britain had become a republic during her
majesty the Queen's reign and she
decided to stand as an elected president
she had a wiped the floor with any
candidate yeah I mean that wouldn't be
the case with King Charles I mean Gary
lineker would be King Charles you
probably would beat King Charles that
sounds so surprising so so therefore I
think it is
last year as well if I went the other
way 21st century Democratic age you're
setting up a new Society written
Constitution protecting people's rights
the monarchy to an extent at least is
the Pinnacle of a class system
it is it is but when I look at the way
that the American system has worked with
this two-party system fraught with
corruption thought with people you just
have to have a big enough bank balance
to run for president you know the the
division they have in that country I
look at the division in this country I
look at the procession of useless
leaders we've had the one constant we've
had and I genuinely believe this has
been the queen and now Charles we've had
two monarchs in my lifetime and I do
think they provide the country with just
a comfort blanket which should not be
underestimated why are you laughing
because we don't need a comfort blanket
I mean I think we do actually why I mean
it's so patronizing and we're so
unpadriotic because yes we need a
comfort blanket uh I have never heard a
good argument for the monarchy and it
certainly isn't a net positive you
didn't see any positives about the queen
there's no well I mean it's not about
the Queens it's about the monarchy she
was the head of the monarchy and now we
have for 70 years but now we have it you
saw that just to be clear you saw no
positives in the queen it's not about
the queen it's about the model I'm
asking you about the queen well I don't
really know her and that's the problem
we don't know none of us none of us
for 48 years of your life really new
they don't squirm off the old net here
no because the issue is the monarchy did
you not understand that she was one of
the not if the most respected people in
the world well I I think that's
disputable but I mean the point is who
is more respected than her that's a
silly answer give me a name this is a
deadline this is a dead end I'm not sure
do you not see any positives in the
queen you'd say no
the argument is about the discussion is
not about which monarch is that because
the Queen's no longer there so that's
happened to you the answer is discussion
is whatever I decided it's going to be
that's our history I'm asking you we now
have you made a statement about about
the monarchy and I said to you did you
see no positives from the queen I saw no
positives had in the queen as they head
of state right you didn't see any
benefit to the country in terms of the
extraordinary esteem and respect she was
held around the world the fact that she
met more presidents than anybody else I
don't think maybe more prime minister
actually it makes a huge difference it
makes no difference why don't you ask
the presidents why don't you ask all the
presidents who queued up when she died
if we actually talk about the monarchy
rather than the person
why because the queen is no longer
because of your of your monarchy
deriding life the question was this
extraordinary figure who actually and
she would never have been enormous
respect she would never have been Quinn
if her uncle wasn't a Nazi sympathizer
who was thrown out she would never been
queen or she would have had a very short
way but she was
completely random and she's no longer
here random she was the only model we've
had the new one the issue is what
happens next now the monarchy is is
actually
because the whole at the top of the
story was what's where did you worry
about what you're reading
it's my show
right and here's my question for you
stop reading that I'm not reading that
somebody else has written that not me
look at me look at me and here's my
point what you're not factoring in in
this General whine about the institution
of the monarchy is the extraordinary
influence and Power in my estimation
that her majesty the queen had and I
think Charles can continue which is a
fiction which is not a fiction
summarize why the monarchy is a bad
thing right it stands against our
Democratic principles the institution
has been accused of all sorts of
questionable Behavior it's highly like a
politician it doesn't matter I apologies
it doesn't matter it does for the roles
the politicians to be thrown out we
can't throw Charles out to the next
election because there is no election
and it's also bad for our constitution
it centralizes power in the hands of
government at the expense of Parliament
and people so the whole point of having
a republic and no one no serious
Republican in this country is arguing
for a U.S system working for a
parliamentary Republic which limits
power of the politicians which has been
going really well Independence isn't it
and hasn't it what has our parliamentary
system well no because that's the whole
point appears I was arguing that we
reform it by becoming a republic and
change shifting power from government
Department to people having a written
Constitution yes and a president like
they have an island in Germany who
actually plays these two Ardent
Republicans here right that's fine
they're entitled to their opinion but
the polls are also entitled their
opinion you gov poll in October after
the queen died about a month later
um so keep the monarchy 60 abolish the
monarchy 24 don't know 15
overwhelming support for the monarchy so
these two guys can rant about the
monarchy but the bottom line is going
with October recently it's now 30 55
it's Contracting it gross there is a
growth in support for abolition and
there's a problem because people like
you are running around screaming get rid
of it that's the whole point and so
thank you very much for putting that
down to my efforts because the the
points
what do you sit with this
so I think it's it's quite astonishing
actually to say that the monarchy isn't
important to this country and isn't
important to the people of this country
I think that's why peers is so surprised
at what you're saying because as an
immigrant as one adopted
um into this country there is no doubt
in my mind that the queen has played and
the queen and the monarchy has played an
incredibly important role in society and
one that is reflected I think from
childhood right up to and we can see
that not only from sadly the passing of
the queen where I think 4.6 billion
people around the world
watched that fantasy and this is the
problem that the monarchy relies on
fantasy it may be a fantasy I think it's
the world
and so I think it is surprising that you
can sit here and at least at least
acknowledge that the figures
I go around the world I haven't been to
the United States but I'm not you've
never been to the places it doesn't
matter because no one is arguing for you
you keep responding by saying it doesn't
matter because you don't want to answer
the question you haven't even heard the
question yet no one is arguing I haven't
asked you the question yet
here's my question if you've never been
to the United States I've lived and
worked there for the last 20 years then
you will have no comprehension of the
extraordinary respect they have for the
queen for King Charles now for the
monarchy and it is an abiding respect
that they have and that's why they all
want to come on the state visits and get
the red carpet treatment and I think
it's actually really important to our
special relationship with the United
States the world's number one superpower
I have it but the the royal family have
been able to be this bridge constant
Bridge through all the political turmoil
Alex well I'm just going to say that
I've been the last direct experience
that the Americans had of monarchy was
George III yeah which which doesn't go
particularly well we went well for that
so you've seen go well for us you say
that the Queen's an exceptional Monarch
I agree with you I I got an absolutely
famously with the queen I like Prince
Charles I think he's a great guy that's
not my argument I've got no animals King
Charles
Adams whatsoever yeah but that's nice
that's not because I don't
because if you ask people the question
you're setting up in the case of an
independent Scotland a new country would
you set up with a hereditary principle
or would you set it up on them I think
it's a really good argument and I
actually don't agree that the hereditary
principle that has been established by
this monarchy in the last hundred years
or so certainly I can look at you know
from my lifetime and slightly Beyond I
think it's been a power of positivity
for the country
principles of power I just think you had
this family
well they don't have any executive power
right right
if they don't have any executive power
they interfere the Monarch doesn't
interfere right okay
you think Charles will be a good King it
might be a good thing I think he's
already saying that let's say let's say
Andrew had been the Elder son yeah he
had been a good well he's not yeah well
we'll kick this but I mean you know it's
the so it's a lot what do you mean any
worse as a kingdom Boris Johnson
yes but the point in other words
yes but Boris Johnson is no longer prime
minister right let's trust is no longer
prime minister but the greatest
of the last hundred years I would say
was Queen Elizabeth there's not a
credible argument because it is
incredible argument she was never the
longest protected by she was the most
respected in all the polls and anybody
she was not required to do or say
anything of any particular uh
controversy she was never subjected to
an election she was never suggested to
uh subject she would have published
yes
he would be defeated heavily because the
point is in an election he would have to
sit here be challenged by people like
you he would have to stand in a in a
studio and be challenged by other
candidates
to any potential positive of the
monarchy went to me it's indisputable in
the last hundred years which is let's
say the modern times of the monarchy
that they have been a Force for good but
they haven't but they have not good what
good have they done what they have done
they've propped up a rotten Constitution
they have been a secretive Institute the
single biggest events in the world
outside of massive news tragedies and
disasters and Terror attacks have been
the big Royal events look at the last
year alone the death of the queen and
her funeral so that's a really positive
thing no no no what's positive is the
way that we then acknowledge these Great
Moments in the royal family and we
recognize how influential in the world I
love 13 only 14 of the country wanted to
celebrate the Jubilee uh last year in
2011 79 of the population
true statistics
celebrate you girls polling 14 wanted to
celebrate it you give polling in 2011 79
were not interested 2018 66
the bottom line I don't share
a rather successful example of a
presidential system and that's the
Republic of Ireland they've had a
cracking series of Presidents by any
estimation you know Mary Robertson many
Michaelis uh president Higgins I mean
I've been first class presidents in the
presidential system so but well because
your argument seems to rest on her
majesty the queen was an exceptional
woman I agree I think King Charles is
the truth is if you were still there
don't be leader as we've just seen with
you with the queen you'd have been
brown-nosing away with the new king for
your heart's control
was the death of the queen I think it
would have been ridiculous
I have been I have do I think that he's
the very best that we have to have to
offer we will find out what is it that
you want do you want a referendum do you
want a brexit style split this Society
doesn't need that the monarchy is loved
in this country whether you accept that
or more elections of the kind that we
have with Liz Trump I think the power it
is
we can't outlive the lettuce
lasts 70 years as a as a lovely child is
not going to the last seven countries
who's a calming influence respected
around the world or Liz trust you
couldn't survive Charles who refused who
refuses to pay income tax refuses to pay
inheritance tax demand secrecy was
accused by me to the police of uh
to contribute around 2.5 which is
million pounds which is not you've seen
not true to every stat you don't like
you think you have a lot of baloney
stats he is you literally just dismiss
completely delusional aren't you you
dismissed you go stats you're quoting a
report that has no sources whatsoever
there is no evidence whatsoever that's
good financially this country and it is
a massive drain on our resources but
that's not the reason but they put MPS
expenses into into the shade with them I
respect your opinion but you're
completely wrong uh Alex good to see you
thank you very much Cindy Paula I think
you're staying with us only yeah you are
uh you're not I'm afraid